hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar single cell
and label free binding affinity
applications
with genentech i'm susie valdez of
labyrinth and i will be your moderator
for today's
event today's educational web seminar is
presented by
lab roots and brought to you by
biosensing
instrument to learn more visit them at
biosensingusa.com
now we encourage you to participate
today by submitting any questions you
might have during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
at the end of the presentation you may
also submit any technical issues here as
well
if you are having any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation
i'd now like to welcome our speakers
elaine mai senior scientific researcher
at gin and tech
and dr xi jie wu application scientist
at biosensing instrument
before handing it over to our speakers
we have two
questions for our audience members our
first question
have you heard about spr microscopy
and now our second question what
tool are you using
to measure affinity and kinetics
and thank you very much for your time
answering those questions
and your participation dr wu welcome
you may now begin your presentation sir
thanks for the introduction my name is
shigeru
from biosensing instrument today i'm
going to
talk about the basic principles and
applications of surface plasma resonance
microscopy
before we start talking about sprn
please allow me to say a couple of words
about biosensing instrument
buzzing the instrument is located in
arizona usa
and we started in 2005. so since
2005 we have developed a series of
platforms for specialty spr
management particularly in 2017 we
developed this new tech platform
called sprm which is very well
recognized
by the industry and received quite a few
awards from different
institutions and is also very well
recognized to receive a lot of
interest from researchers all over the
world
sprm is designed for measuring the
binding kinetic between molecules
and the membrane proteins we all know
that
membrane proteins are the starting point
for disease treatment
the acne occurs for over 60 of the drug
targets today so it's important
for pharmaceutical researchers to
understand the binding kinetics
between the drug molecules and the
targeted membrane proteins
on the other hand spr is a mature
and widely used technique for marrying
the binding kinetics between different
molecules
however to use spr for
marrying the binding kinetics between
the drug molecules and the membrane
proteins
are difficult this is because to use
spr they usually require the
membrane proteins to be purified and
immobilized onto a cheap surface
the process of purifying those membrane
proteins are already
extremely difficult and time consuming
and also
those purified memory proteins
will lose their physiology condition
and therefore may affect their
reactivity
with the drug molecules sprm
is designed to solve this problem
sprm is the label-free technique
that allows you to directly counter a
cell
onto the spr chip surface therefore
you can study the binding kinetics with
memory proteins
directly on the cell surface close to
their physiology conditions
it can provide a real-time analysis and
give you the binding parameters
including the
association and the dissociation rate
constant and the binding affinity
it can also be used to study some
nanostructures
and another particles including species
like
virus bacterias and so on
sprm has three key components the first
component
is the spr unit they include the lysos
the detector and the sensor chip on top
of this
spr unit it is a bradfield optical
microscope which essentially
illuminates the same area looking at the
same area
this optical microscope allows you to
precisely position
and locate the sample to where you want
to do the experiment
they also allow you to monitor the
status of the sample during the
experiment
the last component is a uniquely
designed
flow system and this uniquely designed
the flow system
provides the uh optimize the flow
conditions
to ensure accurate spr environment and
also allow
you to directly culture the cells onto
the chip surface
and maintain the measurement conditions
during the experiment
by combining all three of the components
and the system allow us to measure the
parameters of the binding kinetics
including kaio
and kof and the binding affinity
so how sprm experiments are done exactly
well we know for conventional spr they
use a focused
leader beam and a uniform chip surface
and they get an average spr signal for
the whole chip surface
for sprm on the other hand instead of
using a focused laser beam they use the
collimated
lasers to illuminate a fairly large area
of the chip surface
and then for each spot of the
illuminated area
will give one unique spr signal
now if you map the spr signal for each
spot
in the illuminated area against its xy
position
and you will get a sugar sprm image
of course if the surface is uniform you
will get a flat image with no contrast
now if the surface is not uniform
for example if we have the cell on the
chip surface
and then the cell will have different
physical properties
against its neighboring area and which
would in turn
give different spr signals so the map to
sprm
image will reflect the position and the
physical properties of the cell
now if you introduce some chemicals into
the system
and those chemicals start to bind with
the cell on
the chip surface and this binding will
affect the physical properties of the
cell such as the
stiffness and the surface morphology and
this change
will in turn affects the
spi signal and can be recorded
in the sprm image and the whole binding
process
the association and the dissociation can
be recorded
using a series of spr images
now once you have recorded the whole
process
and you can go back and extract the
information
for any particular spot in the recorded
image and then plot it
as a function of the recording time
and then you will get the so-called spr
sensor graph and this spr sensogram will
carry all the information of the binding
the association
and the dissociation and then you can
analyze the signal
against the theoretical models and from
that
you can extract the binding parameters
including the
kl and kof and the binding affinity
well the typical step of sprm
experiment includes the following first
you will prepare the
chip surface and then you counter the
cell onto the chip surface
and then you supply the running buffer
and when the system stabilize you will
get a stable baseline for the system
and then you introduce the molecules the
molecules start to binding you look at
the association
and then you cut off the supply of the
molecules and to look at the
dissociation
and then you repeat this whole process
for many different
concentrations of the molecules and you
obtain the
uh the so-called the profile
of the kinetic titration type of sensor
gram
and by analyzing the whole data series
and you obtain the kinetic parameters
of the kl and the k off and also the
binding affinity and on top of that
you also get a histogram which reflects
the statistical distribution of those
parameters across the whole studied
cells
to compare the difference between the
sprm
and a conventional spr so the
conventional spr
is a uniform surface and the
protein has to be purified and they
immobilize the
uniformly onto the cheap surface
and then you'll measure an average
single signal for the whole surface
for sprm on the other hand you don't
have to purify
the protein your acne cultures
or grow the cell directly onto the chip
surface
and because you can have many cells onto
the chip surface
so the surface is not uniform it's
heterogeneous
and then you can actually measure the
responses
from all the individual cells
and which give you a localized variant
so that's why sprm
not only can give you the binding
kinetics
for the binding information for the
average cells but also can see the
difference between different cells so
you can see the heterogeneity between
different
cells or even different parts of the
cell
so the major advantage for sprn
is you don't have to purify the protein
and you have a physiology condition
close
to the the native condition of the
membranes
on the cell
so this is one of the earliest
experiments we have done using
sprm so the system we are looking at
is the binding of energy of global
proteins on single cells
so we introduce the wea to the system to
bind with the sugar residues on the
surface so the optical image of a single
cell
is shown in this image and
the corresponding spr image is showing
here and if you look at the two images
the perimeter of the optical image looks
smaller
compared to the spr image this is
because the optical image
doesn't have the resolution to see the
spread the very edge
of the spread cell therefore the spr
image
gave you a more complete and with more
details of the cell
the binding process is shown in this
movie
here so first of all you have a baseline
and then you
introduce the wga it starts binding the
intensities of the binding site
it starts to increase and then you start
to dissociate
and the intensity will decrease
accordingly
and the jump in this
place corresponding to a process we call
the regeneration
which we introduce a chemical
to remove the wea completely from the
cell surface
and after that the baseline may
essentially go back to the same level
as before the experiment starts so the
whole process
is recorded in a series of images as i
said before
so for example this is one of the images
recorded at 550 seconds
and which is about here so close to the
end
of the dissociation process
and with all the images recorded we can
analyze
all the data at different locations
and then we get a map which reflects
the variation the local uh lies the
variation
of the binding activities uh across the
south surface
so the map images shown here are the k
on and a k off of the wga binding
with the receptor with the proteins on
the cell surface
now i will show you a number of examples
for the
binding measurement using sprm
so this is one of the nice experiments
we've done with
astrolenica and the system we are
looking at
is a small molecule az1395
targeting the gpr-39 receptor on
lg ksl the result is shown here
on the left this is a spi image
and on the right is a corresponding
optical image
and the optical image you can see more
clearly where all the
ltk cells are located on the ship's
surface
and each of the color square on the
surface reflects one of the good areas
giving you a good binding data you can
see immediately
the good binding data comes overlaps
with the position of the cell very well
so this tells us we are looking at the
bindings happening on the cell not on
some
empty areas and with all the data
we analyzed we can obtain the
isotherm from which we can
obtain the binding affinity
based on the thermodynamic analysis we
also have
all the sensograms for each of the units
area
and we can feed the kinetic model the
one-to-one binding kinetic model by each
of the sensor gram
and from the fitting we can obtain the
uh
the value but the average value of the k
l
and k of and also the binding affinity
and also we see the because we are
looking at many different
areas and we get a distribution
histogram which shows the
variation of the heterogeneity between
the different cells or the different
parts of the surface
so the results we obtained for the
binding affinity is about 400
nanomolar and the corresponding kn and
ko reported also here
and this molecule is actually very well
studied by
astrazeneca and other researchers so
one of the results reported in the
literature
using a technique called the bsi which
is the back scattering interferometer
and it gives the value about 233
nanomolar which upgrades
very well with our measurement down here
this is another interesting experiment
and
down by a signature the system will be
looking at
a customer molecule targeting the nts1
receptor which is
indirectly expressed on a breast cancer
cell
again the results is shown on the
top images the middle image which is the
optical image and you can see where all
the cells is located
and the corresponding spr image is shown
on the right
the left side is a fluorescence image
and
used to uh validate or to
approve the expression level of the nts1
receptor
on the cell the
analyzed data is reflected by those
colored squares on the
image and again a actually overlaps
with the uh position of the cells very
well
and the results will be obtained from
the measurement
and gives the affinity uh the big kid
value
about two nanomolars this particular
receptor the nts1 receptor this protein
actually has been purified and
studied by dr huber from
rush in britain uk
and she actually used conventional spr
and purifies this receptor and did the
conventional measurement
for the same molecule and the results
she reported is about
400 pico motors for the binding affinity
in the literature there's also some in
vitro uh
studies uh for different type of nts1
receptors and for the wild type
and human type um it
gives different values about like 500
pico motors
and to 8 nanomotors and
our sprm gives the data about two
nanomolars so which actually
fairly agrees very well with those uh
natural studies
this is one of the experiments done by
uh duchess
central in japan and which is looking at
the binding of the histamine and the
gpcr receptors
are igek cell on the
left side those are the positive binding
reactions
of the system and on the left is the
optical image
which shows all the htk cells on the
chip surface
and the on the right
this is the spi response image which
shows
actually the binding activity occurring
which exactly maps very well with the
location of the cell first of all
and from the data we can analyze
and obtain the binding affinity to be
about the seminal molars
between the histamine and the receptor
and this experiment is actually being
verified
using a negative control for the
negative control we actually use the
same
cell and on the left that's the optical
image
and on the right is the s pspi response
the difference here is we use a mutant
history
which shouldn't show anybody activity
and indeed from the spr response
images we see very
low levels of signal which shows the
there's no or very small
binding levels between the
molecules here are three more
binding measurements using sprm
so the first one on the left is done by
takeda
and this is a small molecule targeting
the
gpcr receptor on the cell surface
and we see very positive binding
activity
on the cell and then we have this very
nice distribution curve
and then the average value for the
binding affinity
is about 8 micromolars in this case
and there's also very interested
questions regarding the ion channels
so this is the example showing the
binding of a molecule to the protein
that regulates
the iron channels and again the
optical image and the spr response image
and the we see the
very nice binding responses of the cells
and then the results we get
for the binding affinity is about 2.6
micromolars in this case and
the last example
shown here is actually a example
done by a biotech company in
san francisco and we looking at here
is a small molecule binding to some
receptors on the
htcl and again this the top one is the
positive
measurement and you can see this very
nice
positive reactions and with the value
of 865 nanomolars for the binding
affinity
and this measurement is checked uh
against some negative controls
so actually two different type of
negative controls as
uh performed the first one is the
negative control compound
which means the is the positive cell but
the compounds that will not bind to the
receptors on the cell
the second one is an active cell chip
which is
the hek as the
cell which is not only pressed with the
receptor
and both of these negative controls has
shown very low binding activity
so which further verifies the
result we obtained on the positive
cell so far i have shown you a number of
examples for the binding between small
molecules and the membrane proteins
and here exactly uh antibody targeting
the
membrane proteins which is exactly a
membrane transponder in this environment
again the results is shown here
we have see the very nice good binding
sites
overlapping with the position of the
cell and the good results
from the from the analysis
and gives the nice distribution and the
average values for the
binding affinity and decay r and k off
the binding affinity for this particular
reaction is about 2.9 nanomotors
which agrees very well with the
expectation
from the customer
so all the examples i showed earlier are
done with cells that
are fixed onto the chip surface
so one of the common questions people
are asking is can we do lifestyles
particularly with those people who are
studying antibodies
this experiment let's see is a good
answer to this question
so what do we show here is the full
antibody binding to
some life cells in the growth medium
so if you look at the image of the
system
so on the left this is actually the
running buffer
so it's a color red and if you look at
the signatures even here it's also a
little bit red color
so which tells we are using the
growth media in this case again the
mermaid result
is fantastic and we see the
[Music]
optical image and the consonant spr
image
and also the good binding active
area overlaps very well with the
position of the cell
and from the data we get those nice
distribution curves and the average
value for the binding affinity of this
antibody to the cell is about one
nanomolar in this case
because the spr measurement requires the
cells to stick to the chip surface
without any movement during the
experiment
so it's easier to work with adhering
cells
instead of suspicion cells so the
question is
can we actually measure suspension cells
at all
the answer is yes thanks to one of the
researchers and customer from
pfizer he is working with b cells
and he developed the protocol to
grab the b cell from the solution and
stick
it onto the chip surface
and then do live measurement with the
antibodies so this experiment show here
is the proof concept and the analyzer
used here is the wda
now with all the nice data sets shown
here this is
proof the system is stable during the
whole meriment
and of course in
fiber didn't stop with the wga and they
move
on with this protocol with this
procedure developed
to study the real bindings between
antibodies and the receptors on b cells
besides marrying the binding kinetics
with membrane proteins
sprm can actually have many other
applications
for example it can be used to visualize
the position
and the movement of nanoparticles on the
chip surface
we know the surface plasma wave travels
along the interface
of the chip surface
when you have a nanoparticle on the
surface
and it will change the local electron
density which in turn will interfere
with the travel of the plasma wave the
results
you will see a unique scatter pattern
on the sprm image and this
a unique pattern allows to recognize the
extents of the presence of the
nanoparticles on the chip surface
plus the intensity of this unique
pattern exactly directly proportional
or related to the size
and the distance of the nanoparticle
from the chip surface
this experiment shows the relationship
between the
intensity of the image and the position
of the
nanoparticle the nanoparticle is charged
and we
apply an oscillating electric field and
then the particle will
oscillate up and down at the uh
close to the chip surface and then the
intensity will
oscillate according and in this image
here
it shows the distance and the intensity
of the
interference pattern
one of the interesting applications
based on the activities of nanoparticles
is to look at the effect of antibiotic
on e coli bacterial cell
so the bacterial cell is sitting on the
chip surface
and it's jumping up and down when it's
alive
so once you introduce the animal
antibiotics
to the solution and it will kill the
bacteria cell
and then it will lost the movement so
the experimental results shown here
so the images in the when when the cells
are live
and you can see the position and based
on the intensity of the
[Music]
image and you can see it's jumping uh up
and down
at the surface and once you introduce
the uh
antibiotics and it get cute and starts
to be a constant position not moving
anymore
and this results exactly shown in this
movie
here so when the cells are alive and the
way has become
that killed by the antibiotics
sprm can be combined with
other techniques like electrochemistry
so
we can actually add a potential stat to
the system
and then we can supply uh electric
modulation
and to the system and then using the
uh spr imaging capability
to monitor the local responses of the
chip surface the materials on the chip
surface to the
electric modulation
here are two examples for the
electrochemical applications with
sprm the first one is the
spr based impedance experiment
so what you're looking at is the
responses of sahara cell to the
population's treatment and you have the
optical image the spr image and the
spr based impedance image
so the spr based impedance image
shows the localized responses
of those cells to the trimet
and the second example
it shows the cv using the cv to study
the
individual gold nanowires on the chip
surface so each of the gold nanowire
and we're showing up with the
interference pattern on the image
and they can be labeled from here so for
each of the gold nanowires
and you can have a cv based on the
[Music]
the spr signal so you can see
depending on the size and the
the the conductivities and those
different properties of the individual
gold wires
and they actually see differences in the
cv
so which is proves those nano wires
are not uniform they have different
physical shapes and skills
and the properties
sprm has wide applications so
here is the short list of some selected
applications using sprf
in summary sprm is a label-free
technique
that allow you to measure the
binding connectives with membrane prints
directly on cell surface
and it provides a real-time analysis for
binding kinetics and binding affinity
and they can look at a single cell and
also can look at the heterogeneity
between different cells
it can also be used to study the nano
structures
and nanomaterials
you are welcome to contact uh biosensing
instrument
for any questions or interests
and with this i will pass the time to
mrs yellen mai for her
interesting research interesting
research
thank you very much
thank you ceja my name is elaine mai
from genentech my my talk
today will be about evaluating
biosensing instruments sprm200
which can differentiate between mono and
bivalent binding of anti-hernia
antibodies
to high and low her2 expressing cells
before i delve into the evaluation i
will give you some background
in the context of antibody development
it's very important to know its affinity
and kinetics
parameters since antibody binding to its
antigen
plays a key role for antibodies
selection as most of you may know
k on is the association rate constant
and k off
is the dissociation rate constant
currently antibody selection relies
heavily on solid-faced biophysical
methods
such as spr and octet here is a cartoon
of how spr works
spr basically measures the refractive
index the anagen
or antibody is immobilized on the chip
and then the lining flows over the chip
and the binding event is recorded
this method is amenable for screening
antibody drug candidates
label free and very robust but it has
its challenges
some challenges to determine affinity
are that some antigens cannot be
expressed as soluble proteins
especially for multi-transmembrane
receptors the technique used for
immobilization may impact the affinity
measurement as well
but most of all purify proteins do not
reflect the native structure
function and expression of the
multi-transmembrane proteins
and this is where determining antibody
affinity and avidity on cells becomes
very critical
and especially with the advent of pneumo
antibody modalities as shown right here
these past years with more and more
complex formats with multiple arms that
play on avidity
i will show an example to demonstrate
why it's very important
to understand the cell binding affinity
in this example
tdbs as shown here on the left
bottom are t cell dependent by specific
antibodies with two arms
one with affinity to the t cells and
another to the tumor cells
one of the main challenges is to prevent
on target
off tumor binding to healthy tissues
this extensive work that i will be
discussing afterwards
demonstrated the fine-tuning of
affinities of each arm
is critical for efficacy and
tolerability
here is the summary of the great work
performed by the anti-her2 cd3 version 2
tdb team
led by timu juntilla were they
engineered
different antibody formats that would
favor binding to tumor cells expressing
high her2 and protect the healthy
tissues
that may express low her2 for that
they either have the igg tdb or one fab
igg tdb format
the one fab igg tdb is engineered to
have various low to high affinities to
her2
when they compare the binding of all
those molecules on either skb
or br3 they express high her2 levels or
mcf7 that expressed low her2 levels
there was no difference in binding to
skbi3 for all the molecules
however when binding to low hydrogen
expressing mcf7 cells
these antibodies show a big difference
in binding i want to point to the lowest
and
affinity antibody format that showed
almost no binding here
on the right b plot in red
and this is correlated
with the cell killing experiment where
they looked at killing on high
versus low expressing cells they saw
strong killing
on high expressing cells for both
formats and no
killing on the low expressing cells for
only the one fab
igg lower affinity format demonstrating
they can
increase the therapeutic index by
playing on avidity
this also demonstrates that avidity can
rescue affinity
while preserving antibody specificity
and as such
you can imagine how an understanding
avidity can play a critical role in
antibody selection
in summary antibody cell binding
affinities matters a lot
for informing tissue distribution target
engagement
ptpk modeling to inform dosage
requirement
differentiating antibody binding sites
and lead identification when antigen
cannot be expressed as a soluble protein
and as such with an ever increasing need
to study
binding of new antibody modalities with
their relevant antigen on the cell
surface
we evaluated bio sensing instruments
sprn200
as a potential platform to study
affinity and avidity
hence we sought to design an experiment
to determine
if we can differentiate between
monovalent and bivalent binding to
various cell lines
such as skbr3 and mcf7 with different
expression levels the skb r3 as
mentioned
expressed high her2 levels and mcf7 line
expressed low levels
we started with fixing the cells with
four percent pfa in house
and then we ship the chips with fixed
cells
antibodies and buffers to bi for
measurement
the antibodies tested are an isotope
control anti-gd human igg
one arm tdb antibody with monovalent
binding to her2
and herceptin with bivalent binding to
her2
here are the results that we have
and as you can see for anti-gd human igg
isotype control binding
on skbr3 cells it shows that there was
no binding as expected
and also there is no reliable binding to
determine affinity
and kinetics in this case
here are the results we have with the
specific antibodies
on the high expressing line skbr3 the 1r
monovalent tdb antibodies show only one
histogram
for binding events or our eyes only one
histogram that allows determination
of one kd whereas herceptin the bivalent
antibody on the bottom shows two unique
histograms of rois
note the total number of rois are almost
equivalent
58 versus 66 for both the low and high
affinity interactions with the bivalent
antibody
i will compare this to mcf data later
with the lower her2 expressing mcf7
cells again the monovalent tdb antibody
shows only one histogram for binding
events or r
or rois whereas herceptin the bivalent
antibody shows two unique histograms
of rois as expected and as you can see
the high infinity interaction which is
around 168 picomolar
on the low expressing mcf line relative
relative to the
lower affinity interaction of about 3.3
nanomolar
herceptin has almost a twofold
difference
in roi 45 versus 81. and notice the
lower number of ris
for the higher affinity sites and most
of the ris for bivalent binding
are low if any lower affinity for the
lower expressing line
here are the results we have
comparing the two cell lines with
herceptin side by side
to demonstrate that the binding density
as shown by the total number of rri's
show a difference between the two lines
which indicates there is an affinity
effect
specifically in the high expressing line
skbr 3
there are more binding events with
higher affinity than the mcf7 line
pointing to a higher ability effect on
the high expressing cells
this extra level of information or
receptor binding is unique with sprm
for affinity and ability determination
and thus can be a very useful tool
for studying multimeric molecules at
genentech
in summary we have compared the affinity
with other technologies as well
internally
and i am just showing you one of them
today and here as you can see
sprm's affinities are very similar to
connexas
and also the k on and chaos are in line
with what we expected
the main advantage of sprn-200 over
other assays
such as facts is that there are very few
technologies out there that can
determine kinetics and avidity on cells
since there is a true need to determine
binding kinetics sprm is a prominent
it is a promising technology due to its
ability to detect
multiple association levels with
multivalent molecules using their
spatial mapping function
we look forward to testing the
instrument ourselves in our lab
there are also lessons we learned from
this technology overall
there was reliable generation of
affinity and kinetics
parameters for skbr3 and affinity
for mcf7 however the technology is not
suitable
for cell lines expressing less than 10
000 receptors
of interest and as you can see in the
mcf7 line
there was no kinetics parameters
generated
last but not least um i want to
acknowledge
the successful work that has been done
here involves great collaborations
across different teams in-house and
externally
specifically in-house in our department
the biochemical and cellular
pharmacology group
is debarco and leticia who leads the
team
and mercedes yitchin and margaret who is
our blt members
and also the internal antibody
engineering group
rajesh and jt for their support and also
sharing of information
and externally i would like to thank uh
elizabeth from zapadine
and sugiya and nakimi from biosensing
instruments for
the evaluation of this instrument and
this concludes
my talk thanks for your attention now
we're going now we're going to
start the live q a portion of the
webinar
thank you cj and elaine for that
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar and if you have any
questions you want to ask please do so
now
just click on that ask question box
located on the far
left of your screen and we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for
so let's take a look we already have
some great questions
coming in from our audience member
this first question is for for you cj
surface of this cell has many receptors
how does
sprm detect the binding
of my specific target receptor
thank you yeah i mean this was actually
one of the
common questions people ask and the
there's also actually important steps
for
experimental design so
there's two uh ways or two
protocols for two procedure two
experiment uh
steps we use to uh you know to to
to to uh guarantee that we are marrying
the uh
the right receptor so first of all you
know if you have different receptors so
we
need to overexpress to really express
the
targeted receptor on the cell
and the other sensors who also in this
experiment we include some negative
samples either a cell with
a negative cell with no expression
receptors or
negative chemicals just to
[Music]
to to kick we are marrying the receptors
thank you so much cj and our next
question is for you aline
what was the minimal her2 copy number
required to see cell killing with the
one
fab idg tdb molecule
that's a good question so none of the
cells
that express less than two hundred
thousand her2 per cell
were sensitive to one fat igg tdd
whereas
all cell lines with greater than two
hundred thousand
per two a copy number were readily
killed
by the one fat igtv
thank you so much and elaine and cj our
next audience member wants to know
what are the requirements for receptor
levels in cells to detect the binding
event and can it measure an indigenous
cells um
so what i've shown in my slide
we can't do measurements below 10 000
receptors per cell
uh yeah i mean i basically you know we
are trying to
look at a particular receptor on the
cell
and then the uh you know the good thing
will be if you have uh
you know extensive amount of those
receptors so you
are having a stronger signal so the
bottom line is
the more receptors on the cell and the
better
and then we already looking you know
targeting you know
like a 25 uh 25k
or something and higher
and the census you probably is difficult
to really know the exact number of
receptors
and so if you can already press it you
know the more
the better thank you so much
cj and i want to thank our audience for
these great questions
coming in we have time for a few more
she did what is the range of affinities
that can be measured
by sprm
um well this is
sensitive is reliably varying from
picomotor up to like
below a minimum order range
thank you and what about the range of
affinities that can be measured by
sprm
that's basically the same the question i
just said is
in the range of uh you know picomolar
affinity up to like uh below
midi motor i think you choose thank you
and cj could you explain a little bit
more about why
sprm's show two peaks in the histogram
and this is an interesting
question actually uh actually the uh
elaine just showed the
results in her presentation so
the um the synthesis
based on the sprm so the sprm
is is not like the conventional spr
so it's uh because it's a imaging
technique so you basically you're
looking at a big
area and then you divide your whole area
into small regions so each of the region
and you can give as a measuring unit
you can give you one sensor graph one
spi response
so this small region can cover actually
maybe
part of the cell which have receptors
you know uh located in this region now
so if you have like a different
type of receptors or different binding
molecules
so bottom line so if you have different
reaction uh kinetics uh responses
and then the uh
then this uh fprm will look at those
responses locally and at the end so you
from uh
you get a collect all the responses from
all over the surface and you put them
together as the histogram so you get a
statistically a global
picture of the responses from the whole
cells and the whole samples
have those different responses and you
will be able to
see like uh you know two peaks or
multiple peaks even
and you know reflect the fact that you
don't have the same
type of you have multiple different type
of
binding responses on the surface
thank you so much we have time for one
more question
how do you capture the suspension cells
on the chip cj uh
yeah i mean the sprm requires you know
the cell it's like the spr
experiment so the cells cannot be moved
uh moving
in the measurements because you know it
need to be stable there
and the stay there so
well achieving cell is easier
and for the suspension cells they flow
in the solution
and usually we can capture them with you
know
some chemicals coatings on the surface
and the the example i show you in the
slides is from pfizer and they use the
cell tag
but different uh chemistries can be used
for example like uh polylysine
uh pflb uh those uh
there are different protocols you can
use to capture those uh
suspension cells from the solution and
hold them onto the surface
and do the experiment
tj and elaine i want to thank you so
much for your time today
and for your important research and for
your presentation
i'd also like to thank lab roots and our
sponsor
biosensing instrument for underwriting
today's
educational webcast and before we go i
want to thank our audience for joining
us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted
during the on-demand period will be
addressed by our speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time
of registration and this webcast can be
viewed on demand
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's
live event until next time take care
everyone
and bye bye